[Music]
here's your money briefing for Monday
April 10th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
we're almost done with this year's tax
filing season but here's something every
taxpayer should know as they plan for
next year tips for reducing their tax
bill Wall Street Journal personal
finance reporter Ashley Ebling joins me
now hey Ashley thanks for being here
nice to be here
so Ashley the average tax bill has been
steadily climbing the past several years
it's reached nearly eight thousand
dollars why are tax bills on the rise
this year people are more likely to get
a lower refund or actually a tax bill
because of the expiration of pandemic
enhancements to the child tax credit and
the dependent care tax credit and some
other tax breaks too
so there were also large capital gain
distributions on mutual funds late last
year and that caught a lot of taxpayers
by surprise
if they didn't withhold and put in
estimated payments correctly then
they're going to be seeing these big tax
bills this tax season now how
significant are the expiration of the
tax credits that you mentioned well it
can actually make thousands of dollars
difference on your final tax bill for
example just the child tax credit one
family I talked to they had sixty six
hundred dollars in a tax credit last
year and then this year it's just four
thousand dollars so that means a big
difference in the bottom line when they
see their balance due all right so let's
talk about how people can avoid a big
surprise in their tax bill going forward
what should people look for in their
paycheck so you can avoid a balance due
by adjusting your tax withholding in
your paycheck or you can make estimated
tax payments but you need to do that
well before tax time and this
particularly applies if you get a bonus
and your employer doesn't withhold
enough taxes or if you sell stocks at a
game without offset losses it's a big
deal for anyone with self-employment
income they need to be making an
estimated tax payments throughout the
year and even someone who takes money
out of the retirement account and
doesn't withhold the right amount they
can get stuck with a surprise bill yeah
this sounds like a lot of math involved
how would somebody know how much to
increase the amount of taxes being
withheld in their paycheck so the point
is don't just guess I spoke with an
enrolled agent a tax Pro in Holmdel New
Jersey who said one of his new
york-based clients who took money out of
his Ira to help out his parents last
year he just checked off 20 for
withholding but he's actually in the 35
percent bracket so between that mistake
and an under withheld bonus he owed
about five thousand dollars at tax time
so it's really important to check your
withholding during the year to make sure
it matches your tax bracket depending on
what your income is as your income comes
in throughout the year and one way to do
that is to do periodic checks especially
if you have these events like a bonus
that type of thing or IRA withdrawals
and you can check it throughout the year
at irs.gov now the filing deadline this
year is April 18th but we often hear of
extensions because of special
circumstances and they often have to do
with natural disasters what happens to
people who live in declared disaster
areas so this year unfortunately has
been a really bad year for storms and
you have to be on the federally declared
Disaster Area list your county to
actually qualify for the relief but if
you are on that list you might have
until October 16 2023 to file and pay
your 2022 taxes so that's residents in
all but three counties in California all
of Los Angeles County for example even
if you weren't personally affected by
the storm you have until October 16th to
file and pay same goes for some counties
in Alabama and Georgia and taxpayers in
certain counties in New York have until
May 15th and taxpayers in certain
counties in Arkansas and Mississippi
have until July 31st so again go to
irs.gov and check for the IRS disaster
tax relief list and so what some of
these people have been through this
extra time could really be useful for
them right later due dates mean
taxpayers can park cash and money market
fund or a CD to earn interest and pay
later
it also helps those who can use extra
time just to get their money together
now what if people outside of disaster
zones simply can't pay their tax bill
so tax advisors suggest asking friends
and family for a loan before resorting
to putting a balance due on a credit
card with high interest or turning to
the IRS
super important to remember as soon as
your payment due date passes and the tax
bill goes unpaid the IRS begins charging
interest and penalties and they're
pretty high the current interest rate is
seven percent the penalty for failure to
pay is half a percent of the unpaid
balance each month or six percent a year
up to a maximum of 25 percent now Ashley
does the IRS offer some sort of payment
plan yes it does but
that in the if you're on the payment
plan you're still paying interest and
penalties
the penalty does get reduced for
taxpayers who enter into an IRS approved
payment plan it drops to a quarter of a
percent a month or three percent a year
but even then you're still paying 10
percent on an annual basis one thing to
keep in mind is the failure to pay
penalty can be waived entirely for
taxpayers with no late filing or late
payment penalties for three years and
what if you can't pay all that you owe
even over time so there are more options
if you can't pay all that you owe
there's a partial payment plan or kind
of The Last Resort the taxpayer can
secure what's called an offer and
compromise and the offer sometimes
allows taxpayers to settle tax debt for
less than what they owe they require
substantial Financial disclosures and
can take six to 12 months for the IRS to
consider all right that's Wall Street
Journal personal finance reporter Ashley
Ebling Ashley thanks so much for being
with us thanks for having me and that's
your money briefing I'm J.R Whalen for
the Wall Street Journal
[Music]
thank you